how's Gomes man is pure damn that is bad
eh yes why am I never relate this game
before yeah damn press fire to continue
this is like I accept the Bros and
inception out of baby I am girl what is
this oh god damn that is badass
oh god damn I'm sexy hahahaha alright
oh god damn that is better yes who needs
a ladder when you can do whatever that
is there we go
America freedom America the submit is
gonna get flagged I better continue so
the American flag is at checkpoints [ __ ]
game G what you die from holes what kind
of [ __ ] is this god damn that is not
freedom this game is racist
what is this hello unlock the broom
Raimondo Rome and oh is here god damn
dramatic i'm your text from ahaha what's
that
yeah Rome and o is here ah reminders
here secretly queer
oh it's Illuminati ratting haha
hahaha
I need more of a challenge never mind
I've described this America and shed
that's all I got to learn to that
goddammit
Oh Romano's down there and get stop
eating the printer what the [ __ ]
alright save Raimondo wait Baracus be
April Rakus
Baraka's Baracus
towstee just the way I like a baby
what's up babe what's up baby girl oh
why would I save a character she just I
can shoot them with their dad that's how
you know it's a good game
what do you get stop eating the damn
printer Brody Walker oh damn
ginger [ __ ] what are you doing with uh
America
ha
two more rescues until the next aisle
okay area liberated of course he thinks
he can escape big again
oh please like minecraft my god
minecraft totally ripped this game off
oh what a game what it what the [ __ ] oh
I got squished
oh I'll die it ain't done in good what's
up baby
that's right
Oh God how could I get squished if I'm
midair yeah
BRE ever man oh my [ __ ]
hello he shoots now how am i shooting
what what it touched my pinky PO I am I
am NOT racist see how I save him by
toasting him bro hard what the [ __ ] is
that why it's obviously from die are you
stupid
ha forgive the [ __ ] oh I do backflips
and Chin's like a knight
how did I do that whoa whoa what I
believe it Oh snow goddamn I'm really
bad at this
that's okay what's up headshot that's
what's up again America must be saved
there's only one man good enough for the
dead and his name is ginger beer pair
tonight okay where did this guy now oh
hello
alright get enough of me baby America
Nellie's
oh [ __ ] the kid falling that's right
oh [ __ ] what up this games actually
pretty cool oh okay what's down there no
I don't trust it it's a traffic oh hey
man stop no you made me die now are you
happy
don't day what do you want here who
built this ground man don't don't don't
don't
hahaha and that's how it's done baby oh
god don't explode don't explode Mack
Brower what the hell what this is oh he
keeps throwing dings that's pretty
badass
take that he throws a check in with
that's genius
why didn't I think of that
that's amazing America so we put on the
flags we kill all the enemies and that
would blow up the entire thing what's
the point
hey best game Oh God god damn oh yes all
right
sup ladies you want chicken
we just love chicken ha ha ha it's joke
I tried it
hey one chicken nah [ __ ] oh damn that's
awesome
hey you though you want some chicken
america chicken oh god they have doggies
check it I'm all out of chicken
Oh goddamn it what do you do oh god yeah
oh and 60s ass just like real life baby
you want a piece of my needs I can
explode in your face if you want me to
quit
America I gotta say it's a fun game I
really enjoy playing it it is I goddamn
it I want I want the grenade guys like
the best oh [ __ ] what the hell did I
just do
hey baby oh damn this special attack is
the best hey man how you doing
Oh what Bray it should be Brody no I got
damn that is my name this game is so
freakin mad what up ladies
chop chop why I can't chop that oh there
you go five to get oh no why did I take
it I'm sista quick take this
it's an American souvenir maybe oh jeez
what just happened
it's raining blood Emma excellent hey
baby okay
take it it's an apple for your [ __ ] I
don't know what don't read into half the
fingers
hey guys have a souvenir
great
whoever said video games are violin
let's try and stab some people maybe
that will be fun I'm Chuck map Rhett's
up Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck hi my
friend yes chicken man baby you want
some chicken
this game is racist I love it
I'm just kidding is there a checkpoint
better get the checkpoint right yeah I
got it
this has to be the Swedish guy who else
would be here you like some chicken oh
god damn it
better throw my chicken get the chicken
stupid ass Howard yeah oh let's go and
try the chicken
uh-huh I'm mad I might love this game a
little bit too much oh [ __ ] what is that
tract doing there it's not called a
tract well what do you know my life
egg guy don't distract goddammit this is
great therapy after you play Dark Souls
man oh god what are you doing what are
you doing maybe what do you know
I got [ __ ] sake man what do you do I
goddamn it that's chicken take it for
everyone
hey everyone loves my chicken hey you
guys like chicken what's a chicken you
like some chicken there you go you're
welcome America
this is so Power Rangers Go Go Power
hello so honest ah what up ladies I
wonder where his special attack is oh
damn oh also oh no what a check why do I
keep changing what is his special thanks
yeah yeah Oh giant fart oh of course I'm
wearing shorts and it's not even hot our
baby damn bro drew Oh justice I know
he's shooting at my fret up and he's
spontaneous oh yeah [ __ ] no I want him
back
it was awesome America box Oh finally I
buzzed by the awesome what the [ __ ] what
is it American Oh mo of course I gotta
save my friend
please be judge I'll get ya be I wish
you could choose I'd be awesome
are set that way
what are you doing get out of heat
O'Shea yes just knock out damn it ticket
check out who was chicken
you guys like chicken Betty dude you
[ __ ]
okay oh god I really forgive me
unless in two minutes a little over two
minutes but justice was saved
goddamn it I want me I want judge give
me done come on give me judge five oh
that one great yeah I'm still alive
never mind haha yeah now what growing
back oh man somebody brooch Oaks man how
far are they gonna push it okay
Jesus this gun oh god no no I wanted to
find a special immediately dinner serve
baby the main course I was [ __ ]
awesome
yeah with backward I could play these
all day this is awesome I love it I'm
happily surprised by this game for days
oh oh well America I live way too much
at my own jokes it's [ __ ] awkward
alright
don't shoot me you [ __ ] why kill Chuck
mayonnaise the [ __ ] are they to doing
seriously what it did he eat his friend
America can't do that America is this or
is this not America freedom oh god damn
it too much freedom Yolo
that's what happens when you get too
much freedom you yellow justice I'll
Batman not really but what Batman
chat getting humped it's [ __ ] gun man
Jesus I'm down nice isn't she goddamn
alright judge justice justice punch what
up ladies
what up Ward's the brofist up there a
button god dammit god dammit I guess you
can't ask any through anyone America
America how can America too much freedom
ah yes yes ha ha
later noobs Hey Go Go Power Rangers spy
a little bit more [ __ ]
what a baby oh god yeah what are they
doing
they sound like Homer Simpson ha ha ha
hey come on you can't touch this
what nice do this stealth style baby
[ __ ] yeah oh god what is that oh god no
what is happening
high-speed route I [ __ ] rushed it I
got it bucket ha ha still badass 1 2 3
20 seconds one more rescue until the net
what's an unlock a new character this
character has more games than what this
game has more tag [ __ ] it I don't know
English god damn it this guy snake bro
what bro skin I don't mean space Oh God
what'd I just do I don't know buddy like
oh [ __ ] I love how they sound like Homer
Simpson it's the best friend all right
let's save this guy Chuck no a sturdy
rescue baby that's right even my farts
are dandy baby
some once your mod this game and change
to flag the Swedish flag cuz it wouldn't
make any sense though
punch it
you want to fight with this fight with
it oh I can control oh that's awesome
bananas
and try baby [ __ ] bananas I'm
gonna kill them anyway it's a baby why'd
I do that
hahaha alright pigs oh no I'm sorry guy
me kil nothin can you ride the pig hmm
best game ever you can make the pig
teleport this game ever
you guys like check out how what are you
doing
America thank this present from America
stay toasty my friends oh god what is
happening down they take this and this
and this and they and thanks and thanks
can you take this that's right for you
standing at hey take this thank me later
although it looks like I'm just staring
in their ladder hahaha what the [ __ ] are
you guys you guys want to fight huh you
guys want to join the cause we'll grab a
gun and let's go baby
my throat is starting to hurt but that's
never stopped anyone good except maybe
singers and Britney that [ __ ] is a
[ __ ] what are you doing here Mecca oh
why don't you dad Mecca that's better
you [ __ ] pig lover lucky me there's
two things I hate
and [ __ ] piggies I don't like
bananas too but that's a different thing
generally explaining shooting the guy in
the dead victory
oh well close enough what the [ __ ] oh
it's a pants battle the [ __ ] am i how am
I gonna kill him you can't have an
interest sequence that zooms in her man
if I'm an angry take this and this and
this and this breakdance baby
breakdown for America ah oh hey there
sweetheart
you like it when I do this I can touch
you in all kinds of places baby don't
run away I love you
you're my senpai I can be your lover all
night long baby girl
let's go on holiday together we can go
to how he didn't die welcome what what
is he doing
looks like a job for blade blade has to
take over
I got them why aren't you dead seriously
why aren't you dead oh god it's gonna
blow oh god he's gonna oh god he's gonna
cheat this looks like the tea on the
pills oh nevermind pills can never die
except that one time that he died a lot
of times he dies that it's not his fault
yes too badass take this and this oh
[ __ ]
alright we're back here ain't nobody
stopping when Pony Parties popping yes
four had put a pipe on a girl
oh my go go go I'm like oh go go for
America baby
oh my go for a Mart that doesn't even
make sense I don't [ __ ] know what I'm
talking about
Oh God - all the babes - you saw what it
means god damn it in his badass doesn't
matter I'm the pro manator the pronator
never I don't even know what its
brominated us I didn't watch the movie
to be honest I'm a little embarrassed by
it but that doesn't mean you have to
give me flak for it that's right baby
explode all you want how much life can a
[ __ ] have bad okay guys I'm done diddly
ridiculous come on come up suck it
do whatever you want with it just play
with it for a little while
I got I can fly okay all right a [ __ ]
not [ __ ] this is very bad
high for America America what America I
trusted you
check-in you want chicken hey guy
someone check any well I got your back
bro
more chicken now you're just being
greedy man all right fine
oh [ __ ] oh no don't die no that's badass
man I don't know how to kill him
seriously what the [ __ ]
what Cecilia what's their dealio man
infinite health everything else dies so
quickly I like Ana I don't I don't
understand what is it going now oh [ __ ]
he's Craig Craig Craig Craig what is
that
daddy is that supposed to be de lethal
my lips are more lethal seriously
it's true have you tried sucking on them
well then you don't know a guy what he's
going I'm so lonely
it's so kawaii and I'm not so guy enough
for him we can never be together
it's a sad true form a downer
relationship oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] dogs man what do you want oh I
get it I get it
chicken I have one life left
chicken I got it I got it
no I get it no but stairs there got it
stop throwing BAM side me not cool
yes for freedom yeah I take me forever
but whatever Freda all right I really
got to stop here Oh goddamn it away in
New City
all right all right dress looks like I
have to end it here but let me know if
you want me to play more I would love to
it's a lot of fun maybe like if you did
really appreciate it as always thank you
for being subscribed and thank you for
being a bro not being a little not in
that way let's tail